bonjour à tous bienvenue à bruxelles au
coeur du parlement européen c'est parti
comme d'habitude pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne autour d'une
thématique quel modèle agricole pour
l'europe de demain dans cette émission
je vous emmène en allemagne les fermes
industrielles peuvent elles être une
solution à la crise agricole que
traverse l'europe
nous avons été à la rencontre d'un
agriculteur à la tête d'une exploitation
de grande taille mais d'abord
l'actualité le salon international de
l'agriculture a ouvert ses portes cette
semaine sur fond de crise agricole
une situation explosive le point avec
simon blain
ambiance tendue cette année au salon
international de l'agriculture à paris
lundi le premier ministre manuel valls
et suit un affront de la part des
agriculteurs le pas pourquoi tu vas là
samedi françois hollande est
sérieusement chahuté durant
l'inauguration du salon qui nous écoute
plus le stand du ministère a même été
saccagés quelques jours plus tôt des
dizaines d'éleveurs et de producteurs en
colère pousse le ministre de
l'agriculture stéphane le foll à sortir
de son domicile au mans pour venir
dialoguer avec eux tous demandent des
mesures fortes pour sortir de la crise
et ce n'est pas la baisse des charges
annoncées par le gouvernement qui
apaisera les tensions
le secteur français souffrent de graves
difficultés comme ses voisins européens
en cause la chute des cours et l'embargo
des produits européens par la russie
face à ce marasme manuel valls
interpelle le commissaire européen à
l'agriculture phil hogan pour imposer à
bruxelles des solutions collectives
la commission doit faire maintenant des
annonces fortes prochain conseil des
ministres de l'agriculture décisif le 14
mars
alors peut-on ou pas sortir de la crise
agricole et y at il des remèdes en fait
à ces crises multiples qu on connaît
maintenant depuis plusieurs années c'est
je vais en parler avec mes invités josé
bové bonjour bonjour on ne vous présente
plus un vous êtes député membre du
groupe des verts ici au parlement
européen et vous êtes ex leader de la
confédération paysanne et vous faites
partie de la commission agriculture au
sein de ce parlement
tout comme marc tarabella qui est à côté
de vous député socialiste et démocrate
belge merci et bienvenus j'ai en face de
vous yvan hayez bonjour vous êtes
secrétaire général de la fwc la
fédération wallonne de l'agriculture
alors quand on voit ces images un peu
impressionnante vraiment de tension au
salon de l'agriculture comme on en a
rarement connu les propositions du
gouvernement français en fait sont elles
suffisantes on a juste proposé une
baisse des charges et on voit que
globalement les négociations entre le
secteur de l'agroalimentaire et
notamment les producteurs laitiers
achoppent
alors c'est quoi la solution josé bové
je pense que déjà ça fait plusieurs
années que les paysans tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
nous nous avons tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé ici pendant la réforme de la
pac
parce qu'on a vidé de l'ensemble de la
politique agricole tous les outils de
maîtrise de production et les derniers
qui ont été démantelées ce sont les
quotas laitiers français à partir de
2003 que la décision avait été prise par
madame fischer bol qui était commissaire
européenne à l'agriculture
et depuis tout a été mis en oeuvre et
tous les gouvernements qui se sont
succédé au niveau européen on cautionner
ça alors qu'on savait qu'à partir du
moment où on ouvrait les vannes de la
production est bien y allait avoir une
surproduction laitière en plus le marché
suivra marché ne suivrait pas donc
effondrement des prix et une fois de
plus ce sont les paysans qui paye les
pots cassés yvan hayez est-ce qu'il faut
rétablir les quotas laitiers quand on
voit que le prix de revient aujourd'hui
et ont tout autour de 33 centimes voire
36 centimes le litre qu'il est vendu 26
centimes sur le marché certainement
renoué en tout cas avec des outils de
régulation des marchés josé bové a parlé
d'un des aspects qui est
les quotas et là je souscris pleinement
à ce qu'il a dit est depuis 2003 on n'a
cessé de dire que c'était une sottise
que de sortir les capteurs mais aussi
les outils de gestion notamment les
niveaux d'intervention et nous serons
avec la fédération wallonne de
l'agriculture présents ici à bruxelles
au prochain sommet des ministres
européens de l'agriculture est en mars
venir demander qu'on renoue avec des
outils de régulation
l'important pour les agriculteurs avant
tout quelles que soient les aides qu'ils
puissent recevoir c'est d'avoir des prix
rémunérateurs
parce qu'effectivement la il fonctionne
à perte marc tarabella
est-ce qu'on peut compter sur phil hogan
qui est le commissaire européen à
l'agriculture pour revenir un petit peu
sur ses décisions et remettre des quotas
laitiers alors qu'on les a supprimées ya
plus près ce que tu es un an maintenant
ça m'étonnerait parce que commissaire
hogan jusqu'à présent à d'abord nier
qu'il y avait une crise n'est pas
quelqu'un qui a pour leitmotiv de
vouloir réguler les marchés
c'est plutôt un ultralibéral qui veut
laisser faire le marché comme
l'essentiel est de la commission
européenne mais pas uniquement
l'ensemble des états membres la majorité
des états membres ne veulent plus régulé
quand on dit l'europe c'est la
commission c'est aussi le conseil s'est
aussi les gouvernements et dans ce
parlement nous sommes minoritaires avec
josé bové et quelques autres en tout cas
minoritaire on voudrait avoir des
mécanismes de régulation que ce soit les
quotas ou une politique de maintien des
prix ou d'être contracyclique les
américains le font
jean pierre a rappelé les aides qu'on
trace écrite c'est quoi ces cordes comme
les américains quand le marché n'est pas
porteur
eh bien ils ont défilé sécurité c'est à
dire un prix compensatoires pour leur
assurer un revenu ici on fait exactement
la verse alors j'attire l'attention sur
le grand danger qui nous guette le tti p
le traité transatlantique au livre
agricole se serait catastrophique de le
signer et d'ailleurs les américains ont
déjà sortir documents officiels qui
montrent que je gagnerais et que nous
perdrions et là ce serait encore une
crise avec beaucoup plus de deux
problèmes pour toute une série de
productions notamment la volaille le
secteur du port de la viande de boeuf
est probablement le secteur laitier
également mais alors le problème pour
être clair c'est quoi c'est la
dérégulation ou c'est le poids de
l'agroalimentaire et des centrales
d'achat qui cherche à faire baisser les
prix on a tendance en fait t'as pas y
voir très clair dans les responsabilités
josé bové de qui on parle en fait dans
cette crise alors je crois qu'il ya d'un
côté le fait de ne pas maîtriser les
volumes
une donc là souvent l'industrie de la
transformation est très intéressé parce
que quand les prix baissent et bien
effectivement leurs matières premières
et plus basse mais eux au niveau des
marges
il continue à maintenir leurs marges
parfois même les augmenter en dix ans la
part qui revient aux agriculteurs dans
la plus value de l'ensemble de la chaîne
alimentaire est passée de 30% à 20% si
le redire que récupère cette alors
qu'ils récupèrent très simple pour
moitié à peu près la transformation pour
l'autre moitié
la distribution est ce renvoi saad aux
ados japon en disant non c'est pas moi
c'est vous etc
il faut pas dû on a en france par
exemple deux grands acteurs
lactalis qui était une entreprise privée
mais familial
aucun compte sur la table impossible de
savoir ce qui se passe pareil dans la
viande autres acteurs privés bigard
aucune transparence donc aujourd'hui
effectivement ces entreprises disent
c'est la grande distribution
quand on leur dit montrez-nous les
chiffres ce que j'aime dans ces années
on n'a aucun chiffre
alors qu'effectivement il continue
d'augmenter alors mais il ya autre chose
à moi j'ai vu ce qui m'a quand même un
petit peu frappés que intermarché et
leclerc qui sont deux grandes enseignes
françaises avaient mis en place en fait
d accord pour acheter du porc puisque
c'est aussi l'autre secteur qui souffre
de surproduction faim et qui a du mal en
fait à vendre pas à perte et ces deux
groupes avaient mis en place donc d
accord pour acheter le port à prix
plancher est aujourd'hui à cause de cela
bruxelles les attaques et il risque une
amende avant loyers est ce qu'on n'est
pas là dans une forme d' absurdité aussi
de la part de la commission européenne
mais ce que ce qui est dénoncé l' essai
c'est scandaleux quelque part c'est
qu'il ya une déconnexion totale de la
société par rapport à une chose qui est
élémentaire c'est se nourrir une brique
de lait une côtelette de porc mais
maintenant des morceaux nobles de boeuf
sont vendus comme produits d'appel et il
ya une déconnexion totale entre le fait
noble de se nourrir
bon ben là on peut discuter et road y en
eut pas de viande et les quantités par
semaine ça c'est c'est un débat
diététique mais le fait de vendre et
ceux servis
d'un produit laitier qui est quand même
un produit noble qui est le premier
aliment des mammifères de le brader et
de le vendre à au prix le plus bas pour
attirer le consommateur est quelque
chose d'à propre page sur l'alimentation
a baissé ses charges globales en fait
des ménages
il ya une déconnexion qui se fait entre
l'acte de consommation
l'achat de la consommation tels qu on
devrait peut-être rappeler à nos
concitoyens parce que derrière ça il ya
des hommes et des femmes qui travaillent
acteurs finalement c'était changeant ses
habitudes alimentaires et comprendre que
ces aliments là en fait on a un coût qui
n'est pas celui qu'on a fait alors
comment on fait marc tarabella pour
faire plier la masia entre guillemets
agroalimentaire oui moi je n'appellerais
pas ça la mafia d'abord la production
l'agroalimentaire ça transforme 80 % la
production agricole
ce qu'il faut c'est évidemment mettre de
l'ordre moi j'aurais souhaité à l'époque
que le pouvoir public soit le gendarme
du marché et qu'on attribue une force
évidemment négociations aux producteurs
mais avec la tutelle de l'autorité
publique
mais ça on n'en veut pas ici à bruxelles
l'europe n'en veut plus on nous parle de
bureaucratie s'agit pas de démocratie il
s'agit de l'est de la france à ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas au maillon le plus faible
comme vient de l'appeler yvan hayez le
faire en sorte que tous les acteurs sont
autour de la table
l'agroalimentaire la distribution mais
aussi les producteurs est de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse qui ne puisse pas
vendre à perte
aujourd'hui il rentre clairement à perte
le prix moyen du lait est en-deça
largement du coût de production ça n'est
pas normal et ce depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois d'affilée donc ce n'est
même plus que le marché est erratique et
est hyper volatil
il reste anormalement bas et donc non
rémunérateurs c'est vrai pour le lait
c'est vrai beau suffit mais là on voit
que l'on sort une nouvelle fois d'une
négociation avec tous les acteurs et que
sa chope et de nouveau donc
qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir faire pour
que enfin des solutions sorte de tout ça
écoutez moi je pense y a ça a été dit à
la fois par yvan hayez et marc tarabella
way aujourd'hui en un vrai problème sur
les prix moi j'ai été paysan pendant
plus de trente ans quand je livrais une
laiterie mon lait de brebis
c'est eux qui me fixait le prix et qui
me faisait la facture ce qui était quand
même assez incroyable
on fonctionne à l'envers c'est à dire
qu'on fonctionne à l'envers on est le
seul métier celui de paysans
où on ne fixe pas le prix de vente de
son produit c'est celui qui vous
l'achète qu'il fixe ça veut dire qu'il
ya un moment les choses ne vont pas
quand ce prix ne couvrent pas vos
charges et que vous n'avez dégagé pas de
revenu il ya un moment ça ne peut plus
fonctionner donc pour moi je crois que
c'est une chose essentielle et c'est ce
que j'ai demandé au ministre eric tueur
français je dit il fallait faire imposer
un prix plancher où elle couvre les
charges c'est anormal aujourd'hui qu'en
europe on n'est pas cette situation je
la voter ici au parlement européen
j'avais fait un rapport en 2010 dans
lequel je demandais un prix plancher qui
couvre les coûts de production moyens
ça a été voté à une très large majorité
du parlement européen mais en commission
c'est ainsi l'accord reçu alors yahia
depuis de nombreuses années en fait on
nous vend un modèle productiviste et on
a été justement voir un petit peu
comment ça se passait en allemagne avec
ces fermes de grande taille qui ont donc
pignon sur mur sur rue on les a vus en
ex rda mais elles commencent à fleurir
sur tout le territoire allemand
certaines dépréciations exploitation
pardon compte des milliers de bovins et
des dizaines de milliers de porcs alors
est-ce une alternative à la crise on a
voulu aller voir et c'est sammy a
déchiré violette bonnes basses qui se
sont rendus à la ferme de kannberg
reportage
c'est un rituel bien huilé trois fois
par jour pendant 5 heures ce carrousel
voie dès qu'ils les 1200 vaches dans la
coopérative laitière de kennebec en
allemagne de l'est la traite est
entièrement automatisé seuls trois
employés encadrent le bétail surveillé
par huit caméras le voyez là il y à une
caméra on voit les vaches dans la cour
de la haye la rive dans le carrousel là
ça nous montre à quel emplacement elles
sont prêtes
combien de l'est elle donne tout et
identifier les informations sont
récoltés pour savoir à la fin quelle
quantité de lait a été produite dans le
carrousel en allemagne de l'est ce
gigantisme n'a rien d'exceptionnel
du temps de la rda toutes les fermes ont
été collectiviser celle de ken berg a
compté jusqu'à deux mille vaches
après la chute du mur elle a rouvert
sous forme de coopératives privées
gérées par plusieurs familles vestiges
de l'époque communiste ces bâtiments
vétustes sont aujourd'hui inutilisées en
2014 la coopérative a été entièrement
rénové pour résister à une concurrence
de plus en plus rude
ramdam nous nous sommes dit après avoir
produit pendant 40 ans dans les anciens
bâtiments que nous avions besoin de
changer nos conditions de travail
nous voulions le faire au bon moment ne
pas rater le train en marche mais nous
adapter aux conditions que nous impose
le marché mondial
coût de l'opération 10 millions d'euros
les vaches produisent désormais jusqu'à
40 litres de lait par jour soit 10 de
plus qu'avant la présence humaine est
réduite au minimum dix neuf personnes en
tout pour les 1200 vaches même le
ramassage du lisier est automatisée est
envoyé directement dans ces méthaniseur
comme les éoliennes
ils produisent de l'énergie revendus aux
compagnies d'électricité
en effet sur un an la revente de
l'énergie nous permet de financer les
salaires pendant trois mois un mois avec
le méthaniseur un mois avec le
photovoltaïque est un mois avec le parc
éolien une source de revenus
indispensables car ces fermes
industrielles érigés en modèles ne sont
en fait pas rentable un litre de lait
coûte 33 centimes à produire pour un
prix d'achat de 26 centimes dry à 33
centimes ce serait le prix plancher là
on se dirait que notre travail est
respecté mais faire plus d'économies
dans les coûts de production ce n'est
plus possible
nous ne voyons pas ce que nous pourrions
faire de plus vu les millions d'euros
empruntés pour leur modernisation les
fermes industrielles sont vulnérables
face à la chute des cours du lait
l'industrialisation ne protègerait donc
pas les exploitants le modèle n'est pas
rentable et il est de plus en plus
contesté
en janvier dernier des milliers de
personnes défilent tu à berlin contre
l'élevage de masse elle dénonce entre
autres la pollution générée par les
fermes industrielles
car pour nourrir leurs bêtes ces
exploitations cultive des centaines
d'hectares de céréales ou d'herbe
arrosés de pesticides beaucoup d'oeufs
bio aérosols et de substances
proviennent des fermes industrielles qui
sont très concentrés et contaminent
directement l'environnement
on a remarqué que le paysage s'était
déjà a complètement modifié avec les
apports en azote des plantes
complètement nouvelles se sont
implantées en allemagne de l'est la
colère monte dans le brandebourg un
collectif d'associations a lancé une
pétition dans l'espoir d'organiser un
référendum régional contre l'élevage de
masse 80 mille signatures étaient
nécessaires
ils en ont récolté plus de 100 milles
ils demandent notamment la fin des
subventions offertes d'industriels car
les aides de la pac sont attribués en
fonction du nombre d'hectares
celui qui a beaucoup d'hectares reçoit
beaucoup d'argent celui qui a moins
d'hectares reçoit peu d'argent les
élevages biologiques qui se lancent
aujourd'hui au moins deux terrains donc
moins d'argent
donc nous nous disons pas de subventions
liées à la surface
le collectif réclame des subventions
conditionné au respect de
l'environnement et du bien-être animal
le parlement local se prononcera en mars
si les députés votent contre
ce sont les citoyens du brandebourg qui
seront appelés aux urnes
difficile de prévoir l'issue du
référendum mais une chose est sûre ce
modèle subventionné à grands frais
montre aujourd'hui ses limites
yvan hayez alors même ces fermes
industrielles qu'on pensait être une
alternative n'en sont pas une on voit
que le prix de revient là aussi faire le
prix plancher n'est pas atteint est-ce
qu'on n'est pas la fin d'un cycle est ce
qu'on n'est pas la fin d'un monde et
d'un modèle agricole
effectivement depuis toujours parce que
faut rappeler que les agriculteurs sont
avant tout des entrepreneurs les progrès
sur 50 ans de pâques les progrès de la
science de l'accompagnement à grenoble
ils termineraient ils ont naturellement
toujours cherché à se développer à
s'agrandir
heureusement ce qui nous concerne en
wallonie je pense ou à dire qu'on garde
une agriculture qui est relativement au
même très étroitement lié au sol
nous avons peu de développement de
spéculation hors sol
il ya un peu de ports un peu de volaille
mais c'est relativement restreint et
effectivement cette année six roues ces
deux trois dernières années annonçant la
sortie des quotas certains se sont dit
qu'on va aller chercher l'économie
d'échelle pour rester pour tenter de
rester tous ces grandes fermes dans un
environnement mondial marc tarabella est
ce que le modèle justement aujourd'hui
on voit c'est une demande en fête
citoyenne de savoir d'où viennent nos
d'où vient notre alimentation d'être en
capacité de suivre un petit peu son
cheminement et surtout de consommer un
peu responsable est ce que justement là
je vais vous reposer la question mais
est-ce que c'est pas la fin d'un cycle
et est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train
d'inventer autre chose
ceci le contre-exemple de son confrère
votre reportage bien fait parce qu'ils
insistent sur le fait que
l'investissement hyper industriel ceci
n'est plus le faire mais c'est une
industrie qui se sert du vison pour
produire et de et du bétail en
particulier des vaches en l'occurrence
ça ne peut rien à voir et d'agriculture
familiale à taille humaine est liée au
sol avec le traitement des sols et celui
ici ce qui se passe c'est que la ferme
et votre reportage de montres lé pas
plus rentable que celui elle est même
moins rentables et plus vulnérable que
la guilde heureusement qu'elle métallisé
a finalement cassé 30 40 50 vaches ou
100 vaches et qui utilise notamment ses
herbes et qui est lié au sol lui ce rêve
est moins vulnérable parce que il va
avoir moins d'intrants ici on parle de
ses
avec les pesticides qui sont à côté de
la ferme c'est aussi du soja qui vient
d'outre-atlantique et les vaches ne voit
plus la prairie il ya évidemment un
sérieux problème
et puis c'est aussi les mêmes ici qui
nous parle du bien-être animal je
constate que c'est dans le nord de
l'europe que ce genre de d'industrie a
plus le vent en poupe le dal marque
notamment la suède l'allemagne est
malheureusement certains croient que ce
cette agriculture là est celle qui chez
modernise or je ne répète c'est pas le
cas il faut aller typiquement on voit
qu'en france c'est un peu ce que prône
la fnsea fédération nationale soit le
plus gros syndicat qui représente la
plupart des agriculteurs
l'idée c'est de grossir pour pouvoir à
vous atteindre une taille critique et
donc peser sur le marché
et est ce que c'est aujourd'hui josé
bové une stratégie suicidaire quand on
voit et je prends ce mot sciemment quand
on voit qu'on compte aujourd'hui 600
suicides d'agriculteurs parents qui
arrive justement qui n'arrivent plus à
prendre en charge leur exploitation qui
n'arrivent plus à rembourser leurs
dettes
grossir ça veut dire mourir à terme en
tout cas les études aujourd'hui montre
très clairement que ce sont les
exploitations modernisée dans ces
dernières années
qui sont les plus fragiles ceux qui ont
tenté les coûts d'avoir des productions
d'un million de litres de lait
aujourd'hui c'est eux qui ont les coûts
de production les plus élevés au delà de
40 centimes du litre
ce qui veut dire très clairement essais
des études qui ont été faites maintenant
au dessus d'un certain niveau de
production
il n'y a aucun gain de productivité au
contraire ça coûte de plus en plus cher
et donc l'agriculture
ben ne peut pas être traité comme une
usine qui fait des voitures ou des
frigos l industrie comme les autres on
ne peut pas robotisée l'agriculture en
croyant qu'on va faire des économies
d'échelle parce que à la fois il ya la
question du bien-être animal
il ya la question de l'environnement
parce que ces animaux restent enfermés
24 heures sur 24 et pia la question
sociale c'est à dire que c'est toute la
désertification des campagnes qui est en
train de se faire si on a ce modèle en
france demain sur 100 départements on en
a besoin de 15 pour produire c'est à
dire que
toute la multifonctionnalité
l'agriculture disparaît et quand je vois
cette sphère moi j'ai qu'une seule chose
à dire c'est que la viande et le lait
qui sont produits dans cette firme en
fait sont les sous-produits de la merde
qui sert à faire tourner les dix génique
c'est à dire que l'actionnaire semelle
soleil connaît dont les prix peuvent
baisser
et souvent c'est un véritable scandale
et celle ci à l'agroalimentaire yvan
hayez la fin d'un cycle je vais essayer
de répondre même si j'ai pas la réponse
c'est que je voulais simplement dire
c'est que un homme gère un troupeau 60
65 matchs ça c'est un an
voilà le problème c'est que en gérant
correctement ses 65 vaches et gagne sa
vie il puisse élever disons deux enfants
et avoir une carrière qui est correct
alors de deux choses l'une
l'europe en fait l'agriculture couteaux
européens entre 100 et 120 euros par
citoyen européen par an soit on continue
et on soutient le revenu des
agriculteurs
ce qui est en train de disparaître d'une
certaine manière soit
et moi je travaille au niveau de la
filière la concertation chaîne je ne
suis pas là pour faire le le prix des
autres maillons et la marge des autres
maillons je dis simplement que produire
à l'idée de laisser autant il faut
partir de ça chacun a sa marche et une
fille née le consommateur doit être
conscient que c'est normal de payer tel
prix pour le violer alors on voit que
depuis cette crise de plus en plus
d'agriculteurs souhaite passer en bio
parce qu'on voit bien que pour le coup
là le bio fonctionne et sa saison
correctement à des prix qui sont à la
hauteur de l'investissement de
l'agriculteur finalement il faut quoi
monter en qualité pour pouvoir prétendre
à vivre correctement
josé bové moi je crois que d'abord ce
sont les consommateurs qui choisissent
ça qui est intéressant c'est que on
parlait tout à l'heure des
consom'acteurs cee aujourd'hui qui
oriente ils veulent des petites fermes
petite ou moyenne
ils veulent l agriculture de plus en
plus saines avec le bien-être animal
et ils veulent des produits de la gamme
sans pesticides 10 % du lait aujourd'hui
vendus en france du lait en bouteille
c'est du lait issus de l'agriculture
biologique c'est quand même un signe
très important
donc c'est pour ça qu'on se bat ici au
niveau du parlement ont essayé de
d'améliorer les règles sur l'agriculture
biologique pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse augmenter le nombre
alors justement à ce propos josé bové la
transition est parfaite j'ai ouï dire qu
il y a un rapport avec cela il ya une
négociation en ce moment sur la
labellisation bio et que le rapporteur
qui est membre du groupe des verts au
caudan dans lequel vous êtes vous même
ce serait prêt à lâcher face à la
commission et au conseil pour que l'on
puisse avoir même des pesticides dans
les produits qui seraient labellisés bio
c'est vrai ou pas est-ce que les verts
vont tuer le bio alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est effectivement c'est un
vert allemand martin gosling qui n'est
pas porteur et donc il est aujourd'hui
donc ce qu'on appelle le trilogue au
niveau européen c'est la négociait sa
négociation avec la commission de
monsieur hogan s'est pas celles de dacia
nyolo ce qu'on avait avant été roué le
conseil sous présidence néerlandaise et
là c'est la castagne
c'est la castagne parce qu'effectivement
tout les libéraux aujourd'hui refusent
par exemple qu'on puisse être dans une
logique qui irait on commence avec sa
ferme sur une production
et bien cette production demain
l'ensemble de l'exploitation devrait
être ambiant à l'espace de sept ans dix
ans pour aller dans une dynamique
augmentation impossible de faire passer
ça pour l'instant impossible aussi
aujourd'hui c'est en train de nous dire
ben écoutez il ya peut-être des résidus
de pesticides mais c'est pas grave
finalement
en gros si à des résidus de pesticides
ça va être déplacée mais qui va payer
et c'est là où il faut avec le principe
pollueur payeur cdh les fabricants de
pesticides doivent payer parce que la
question biologie lui quand ils font
plante tout son processus est contrôlé
il a un cahier des charges mais au final
elle se produit est pénalisé ouais
eh bien personne lundi me disent c'est
un scandale marc tarabella
c'est un second temps mais il faut
l'enjeu il est clair c'est dommage que
josé bové n'a pas été rapporteur il
aurait été plus strict que son collègue
allemand il peut pas le dire lui moi je
le dis son collègue allemand est moins
efficace que lui mais lui peut pas le
dire
ouvertement je dis simplement qu'il faut
préserver le bio c'était une niche à une
époque aujourd'hui ça devient à business
ces 22 milliards d'euros à l'échelle
européenne est ce qu'il faut éviter
c'est de le dénaturer
on fait rentrer des gens qu'ils veulent
pas faire du vrai bio et qui trompent
les consommateurs
et ça c'est là qu'elle est en jeu
aujourd'hui la décertification c'est
important et effectivement il ya aussi
le code civil le même en france qu'en
belgique la responsabilité civile celui
qui pollue le champ son voisin doit
payer
il faut pas de fonds d'indemnisation
parce que le problème c'est que ça
déresponsabilise il faut que celui qui
pollue et qui n'a pas pris des
précautions pour préserver le champ de
son voisin bio paye
à un moment donné est clairement la
désertification c'est important la
mixité
moi je suis pas pour la mixité la mixité
dans les une exploitation ça peut très
bien commencer une opposition vers le
bio et on doit y croire et clairement
avoir un vrai bio et les consommateurs
qui se paye 30 à 50% de plus air pas
être trompée et donc il doit avoir pour
moi une grande grande attention à ce que
le label ne soit pas dénaturé les gens
ont besoin d'avoir cette confiance en
plus aller croissante aujourd'hui parce
que la consommation bio est en demande à
l'arrêt attention aussi aux importations
exiger la même qualité des importations
parce qu'aujourd'hui et ça m'a choisi et
tokyo la belle soie pâle et du passé
rapidement il voyait le bio donc c'est
évidement il est clair que le bio est en
pleine émergence il faut l'accompagner
il ne faut pas non plus les tout fait en
allant trop vite
moi ce que je veux dire et j'ai parfois
ça me fait mal parfois d'entendre ces
discussions comme s'il y avait des bons
et les mauvais l'agriculture est en
mutation permanente
il faut l'encadrer il faut l'accompagner
et josé bové avait raison
disons il ya une attente de la société
mais les attentes sont multiples et le
consommateur n'a pas nécessairement le
même comportement en semaine et il est
pressé ou le week-end quand il a un peu
le temps et donc je ne voudrais pas
qu'on oppose les agricultures qu'on la
fasse évoluer et est rappelé que c'est
vrai aussi et les sondages organisés par
la commission le monde entre les
attentes sociétales des concitoyens et
le comportement de ces mêmes concitoyens
en termes de concert à shanghai est à
revoir et 7 bat en face non plus donc
voilà il y a c'est jamais tout blanc
mini tournoi écoutez ce sera le mot de
la fin merci messieurs nous avoir
éclairé sur ces questions complexes et
j'espère que tout ceci vous aura permis
d'y voir un peu plus clair
vous retrouverez la semaine prochaine
ahmed tazir mais pour l'instant pour
nous c'est fini
ciao
vos rangs